michael bury versus kathy wood
this is like two
investment titans absolutely going at it
michael bury's sky on asset management
has owned bearish put contracts against
236 thousand shares of arc innovation
etf the end of q2 the position is valued
at approximately 31 million dollars and
so for those that don't know a put
contract simply is the right but not the
obligation to sell shares in the etf
before a certain date at a previously
agreed on price what does that mean in
layman's terms the price goes down far
enough michael bury is going to make
money now he's betting against ark
innovation etf which is run by kathy
wood kathy has pioneered an active
management etf strategy what that means
is there's an etf that you can go and
you can buy we're not saying to do that
but that's what you can do she then
takes the money and she actively manages
it she invests in certain stocks that
she picks and then they trade around
buying or selling those stocks based on
what they think the price is going to do
in the short medium and long term now
michael bury you may know who he is not
only is he absurd on twitter and he's
deleted his account like a gazillion
times when he's attacked bitcoin and the
bitcoin is pushed back but he also is
famous because he made a very successful
short bet on mortgage-backed securities
during the financial crisis the movie
the big short he is the guy who's
drumming with no shoes on losing all
that money and then when the market
turns he ends up making a very very
handsome profit he is one of about 10
people who are notorious for having
shorted the housing market at the right
time during the global financial crisis
and making an absolute
massive amount of money now it's not the
first time that michael bury has gone
toe-to-toe with kathy wood
indirectly previously buried has shorted
tesla which is one of kathy wood's
famous bets kathy wood has continued to
be a big public proponent of tesla she
has proven mostly to be right up to this
date she continues to think there will
be value accretion to the business we'll
see how that plays out but burry has
been one of the critics so michael bury
in my opinion incredibly smart made a
great
housing short bet
but he's wrong
on tesla he's wrong on technology and
he's wrong on bitcoin we will see we
can't hold him accountable because he
keeps deleting his account on twitter
which is pretty
lame
we have what the arc invest etf holds
and when we pull this up
tesla
is
35
of the portfolio so if you're going to
short tesla
you can basically short this as well or
no i'm sorry this is what this is his
this is his call this is his portfolio
yeah all right so this is michael bury's
portfolio tesla is about 10 of our
extinct so he's betting against he's
been betting against tesla 35 percent of
his portfolios is short on tesla
jesus
that's dumb
so is this really an attack at
arc or is this more of an attack a tesla
and ability to double down on that i
think it's both
right he what it looks like if you look
here at all the puts he's got a
a short on tesla on facebook
uh
what else has he got a short on uh ark
right yeah he's got shorts basically on
uh most of the technology companies
other than google he's on google um so
when you start to look at that it's like
look he okay cool go short technology
that seems like a really bad long-term
strategy i have no clue what's going to
play out in the short term maybe he
knows something i don't know but when
you're 35 of your portfolio is a short
on the single greatest
electric vehicle vehicle manufacturer in
the world
i mean you really got to have some
cojones
to uh to be short there thinking that
that's going to continue to uh uh you're
going to be right on that for a long
period of time you can say what you want
about this certain position but he's an
og for having a movie made about him
[Laughter]
you you did something right um goat
mountain yeah well drum solo and that
was pretty good yeah you seen that goat
mountain all right i agree with you on
that with the uh with the housing short
you can't take that away from whatever
you think about him now whether he's
right wrong about bitcoin tesla
technology whatever housing short goat
mountain you win uh ark innovation in
2021 you can see this is a year to date
change arc's about flat it's down a
little bit in 2021
but it's up from kind of the may bottom
and so it's kind of been going sideways
and so you know there's the potential
that you don't get some kind of meteoric
rise but you also don't get some massive
you know cliff hanging fall uh as well
and so ultimately this is what he's
basically betting against is uh this arc
innovation etf that he believes is going
to continue to go down further hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it